-Serge Klarsfeld, à la case
"profession du père",
vous répondiez toujours
"mort en déportation".
Que diriez-vous
en ce qui vous concerne ?
-Je dirais "combattant
pour la vérité historique".
-Vous avez effectivement
dédié votre vie
à la traque
des anciens nazis.
Tout cela s'est-il fait
précisément au nom du père,
de ce père qui a été
arrêté par la Gestapo
et qui, en se livrant,
vous a épargné ?
-Non, c'est pas
pour mon père seulement,
c'est pour...
toutes les victimes.
Mon père était
l'une des victimes, mais...
Mais la nuit
où on a arrêté mon père,
j'entendais les enfants
de nos voisins crier
parce qu'ils étaient battus
par la Gestapo
pour faire avouer où était caché
leur frère aîné,
donc... C'était...
J'ai toujours senti que c'était
collectif.
-Diriez-vous que
ce 30 septembre 1943
a été le fondement
de votre vie d'homme
et de ce combat ?
-C'est le moment référence
de ma vie
parce que notre père
nous avait dit,
à ma soeur et à moi,
et à ma mère,
quelques jours
avant la rafle :
"Si on est arrêtés,
"moi, je survivrai
parce que je suis fort,
"mais vous,
vous ne survivrez pas,
"et donc,
suivez les instructions."
Nous étions très turbulents,
mais dans la cachette
qu'il avait construite
derrière le double fond
d'un placard,
nous avons été très...
silencieux.
Nous savions que,
d'un moment à l'autre,
nous allions mourir
si nous étions pris.
Bien entendu, ce n'était pas
d'un moment à l'autre,
mais pour nous, en tant qu'enfants,
on savait qu'on allait mourir.
-Votre vocation de combattant
de la vérité historique
est vraiment née
par un matin glacial d'hiver
au camp de Birkenau
dans un face à face terrible
avec les morts.
-Oui, parce que j'étais
très insouciant,
insouciant même de l'avenir
au point de vue professionnel.
Je voulais être heureux,
c'est tout. Et puis...
...je me suis marié
avec une Allemande
qui n'était pas juive,
on était heureux,
mais au moment
d'avoir un fils,
j'ai décidé de renouer
avec mon père ou de...
Pas de renouer,
puisqu'il m'arrivait
de rêver de lui, etc,
mais... de reconstituer
la dernière étape
de son calvaire
et je suis allé
au Mémorial de la Shoah,
qui ne portait pas
le même nom à l'époque,
et j'ai décidé
d'aller à Auschwitz.
C'était la Guerre froide,
personne n'allait de l'ouest
à Auschwitz,
je suis allé à Auschwitz,
à Auschwitz même, au camp...
Le camp qui est
le camp principal.
Il y avait quand même
beaucoup de monde,
des Polonais, des Tchèques, etc,
et à Birkenau,
le camp des Juifs,
il n'y avait personne.
J'étais tout seul
dans un immense camp
et j'ai compris que j'étais,
en quelque sorte,
arrivé moi aussi,
par miracle,
ou par le sacrifice de mon père,
je n'étais pas arrivé là, mais...
...j'entendais quand même
le cri de mon peuple...
-Oui.
-...et donc, j'ai réalisé
que je faisais partie
d'une catégorie exceptionnelle
de Juifs
qui avaient vécu
la pire menace
contre les Juifs
dans l'histoire
et en même temps,
qui avaient vu,
après 20 siècles,
la renaissance d'un Etat juif,
et donc, que c'était exceptionnel
et que je devais donc
et défendre la mémoire
des victimes et défendre...
...la cause d'Israël,
la cause juive,
les causes juives, voilà.
-Serge Klarsfeld,
vous parliez
de Beate, votre épouse,
allemande protestante et la fille
d'un soldat de la Wehrmacht.
En quoi cette rencontre
a également été déterminante
dans ce combat de mémoire ?
-Elle était déjà déterminante,
c'est-à-dire que,
si je n'avais pas
rencontré Beate,
je ne serais peut-être pas
allé à Auschwitz, etc.
C'était en quelque sorte
une synergie
franco-allemande.
Notre couple,
nous étions jeunes,
nous étions pleins d'énergie
et il est arrivé
un événement imprévu :
Beate a été révoquée
de son poste à Paris.
Ca, personnellement,
je ne l'ai pas supporté,
donc j'ai aidé Beate
dans sa campagne
contre un chancelier allemand
qui avait été un dirigeant
de la propagande hitlérienne
vers l'étranger
pendant la guerre.
Elle l'avait attaqué
dans des articles dans Combat,
le journal Combat
qui a disparu,
et elle a été révoquée
pour avoir écrit à Paris
des articles
disant que c'est mal
pour l'Allemagne
de s'être donnée
à un chancelier nazi
alors que Willy Brandt,
lui, était un résistant.
C'était le maire de Berlin,
Beate était berlinoise,
elle aimait Willy Brandt
et donc, tout naturellement,
en tant qu'Allemande,
elle s'est battue contre Kiesinger,
et donc, j'ai décidé de...
Qu'on allait s'engager,
voilà,
et comme j'étais à l'époque
administrateur de l'ORTF,
eh bien, j'étais compétent
dans les affaire de radio,
le chancelier avait été
dirigeant de la propagande
radiophonique,
donc je comprenais
les problèmes
d'organigrammes, etc,
et j'étais en mesure
de constituer un dossier...
-Contre lui.
-...efficace.
-Vous ne vous destiniez pas,
au départ, au barreau.
Cette profession
a d'emblée été un moyen,
jamais une fin.
-J'étais militant
et je me suis plongé
dans l'action militante...
...à 35 ans,
mais complètement plongé,
et j'ai démissionné
de mon travail,
et puis, je me suis dit,
à un moment,
c'était d'ailleurs
en Amérique du Sud,
j'ai lu Le Monde et il y avait
un petit entrefilet
disant que ceux qui avaient
l'équivalence de Sciences
Politiques, du diplôme
de Sciences Politiques,
ceux qui avaient le diplôme
pouvaient entrer
en 3e année de droit.
Je me suis dit...
Comme j'envisageais
de poursuivre
les complices français
des dirigeants allemands
de la Solution finale,
je me suis dit :
"C'est une profession
qui me convient
"parce que je ne sais rien faire,
donc je peux être avocat."
-Auriez-vu pu obtenir
les mêmes résultats
sans collecter les preuves,
démasquer les accusés,
monter des dossiers
et les défendre
aux côtés des parties civiles,
autrement dit
si vous n'aviez pas été,
de A à Z, à l'origine
de ce travail de titan ?
Un travail acharné.
-Non. Il fallait à la fois
être historien,
avoir quand même
des notions de droit
et vraiment, c'était une passion,
et en même temps,
c'était une terre
presque inexplorée
parce que les archives officielles
étaient fermées.
Mon rôle a été déterminant
parce que
j'ai su ouvrir
les archives officielles,
avoir accès aux documents
et pouvoir écrire l'histoire
de la Solution finale
en France et...
...chaque dossier était
très bien constitué,
mais je les constituais
en tant qu'historien et un peu
en tant qu'avocat.
Vous savez, pour être avocat,
il suffit d'être intelligent
et puis de travailler un peu,
mais je n'étais pas
spécialisé...
Le crime contre l'humanité,
ce n'était pas
une branche du droit
à l'époque, et donc...
-Vous étiez un avocat particulier,
puisqu'il vous est arrivé,
à un certain nombre de reprises,
de flirter avec l'illégalité
pour mener les bourreaux d'hier
devant un tribunal.
La fin justifie-t-elle
tous les moyens
pour que la justice soit faite ?
-Pour réussir dans notre action,
nous étions faibles,
très faibles, donc il faut
une action radicale
et énergique.
Il fallait agir illégalement,
assumer l'illégalité
et montrer que le véritable scandale
était l'impunité des criminels
et pas... les illégalités
relativement légères que...
Que nous nous permettions
de faire
et en même temps de dire :
"Voilà notre stratégie"
et lorsque j'ai été,
par exemple,
condamné à la prison en Allemagne
et qu'on m'a dit :
"On vous donne le sursis",
j'ai dit : "Je recommencerai.
"Dès que je peux,
je recommencerai."
L'opinion publique
a peu à peu compris
quelle était notre stratégie
et compris également
que l'illégalité
pouvait aller jusqu'au bout
si la société politique
allemande
refusait de juger
les principaux criminels.
-Serge Klarsfeld,
vous avez également poursuivi
jusqu'en Bolivie Klaus Barbie,
surnommé "le boucher de Lyon".
C'est vous qui avez retrouvé
le télex de Barbie
ordonnant la déportation
de 44 enfants d'Izieu,
une pièce déterrée parmi
des millions d'autres archives.
Finalement, cette trouvaille
relève du miracle.
-Oui, mais...
moi, je ne suis pas allé
en Bolivie, je suis allé
jusqu'à la frontière bolivienne.
C'est Beate qui est allée
à plusieurs reprises en Bolivie,
qui a été arrêtée là-bas, etc.
C'était il y a
plus de 50 ans.
Moi, je suis allé pour essayer
de monter l'enlèvement de Barbie
avec Régis Debray,
et heureusement
que nous l'avons fait
parce que nous l'avons fait
avec un ami bolivien
de l'opposition,
un ancien
haut fonctionnaire bolivien
et 10 ans après
notre tentative infructueuse,
cet ami bolivien est devenu
ministre de la Sécurité en Bolivie,
c'est lui qui a arrêté Barbie,
c'est lui qui l'a mis dans l'avion.
-Bien sûr, mais c'est vous
qui avez trouvé cette pièce.
-Le télex d'Izieu, oui.
-Parmi des milliers de documents.
-Oui.
-Ca relève presque du miracle.
-Je cherchais,
j'avais le feu vert, d'ailleurs,
de François Mitterrand,
qui était président
de la République,
pour retrouver
dans les archives ce document
et ça m'a beaucoup servi,
le feu vert, parce que...
...cela m'a ouvert
les archives
du ministère de l'Intérieur
de l'époque, de Vichy,
et j'ai pu donc avoir accès
à des documents que,
jusque-là...
-N'avaient jamais été compulsés.
-Aucun historien
n'avait pu voir.
-Oui.
-Et le télex,
j'ai fini par le retrouver
dans la cave du Centre
de documentation juive
contemporaine...
...et c'était un document
tout à fait essentiel.
-C'est grâce à ce document
que Klaus Barbie a été extradé
ou vous diriez aussi
que c'est
sa médiatisation ?
-Non, non, il n'a pas été
extradé, d'abord,
il a été expulsé, c'est une...
Comment dire ? Une...
Une solution
que nous avions trouvée
qui n'était pas l'extradition,
l'expulsion.
Notre ministre
de la Sécurité bolivien
lui a fait ôter
sa nationalité bolivienne
pour avoir menti quand il était
entré en Bolivie
et donc, il a été expulsé
et pas extradé
et cette pièce était
nécessaire pour le grand public,
le télex d'Izieu,
mais elle n'était pas nécessaire
pour les jurés
parce que
les copies authentifiées
avaient été...
Avaient été présentées
à Nuremberg et il y avait
une copie à Washington
que je m'étais procurée,
une copie à la Cour de justice
internationale
de La Haye
et une copie
à Nuremberg, donc j'étais
tranquille, quand même,
même si je n'avais pas retrouvé
le télex original.
-Serge Klarsfeld,
c'est aussi
grâce à votre obstination
que Bousquet,
Leguay, Touvier et Papon
ont été poursuivis.
-Oui. Oui, mon obstination,
celle de mon fils,
parce que c'est mon fils
qui a été l'avocat
dans l'affaire Papon
et dans l'affaire Touvier.
Moi, j'ai été avocat
dans l'affaire Bousquet-Leguay,
mais je ne me suis pas
présenté
au procès Papon,
ni au procès Touvier,
je ne suis jamais entré
dans la salle d'audience,
et Bousquet et Leguay, ça s'est
terminé par la mort naturelle
de Leguay, qui a été
le premier inculpé
pour crimes contre l'humanité
en France,
et par la mort brutale,
l'assassinat de Bousquet
par un déséquilibré,
mais je n'en ai pas été fâché.
-Alors, justement,
qu'il s'agisse du procès
d'un vieillard, Maurice Papon,
de la chaise vide
d'Alois Brunner
ou des procès impossibles
de Touvier et Leguay,
décédés avant que la justice
ne soit rendue, à vos yeux,
tous ces procès se valent ?
-Non. Les affaires...
Toutes ces affaires ont montré...
Parce qu'elles ont eu
un grand retentissement.
Des milliers de messages
par la presse écrite,
radio, télé sont arrivés
aux Français.
Peu à peu,
la vérité historique
s'est imposée.
Le rôle néfaste de Vichy
dans ce domaine
a été...
véritablement mis en lumière.
-Est-ce qu'il y a
une plus grande responsabilité
à défendre
la mémoire des morts ?
Etes-vous, au fond,
Serge Klarsfeld,
leur dernier parent,
ou leur dernier rempart
contre l'oubli ?
-Oh, non.
Il y en a d'autres :
tous les historiens qui travaillent
dans le bon sens
en recherchant la vérité,
le chercheur qui travaille
aux archives départementales
sur ce qui s'est passé
dans sa petite ville,
eh bien,
il en fait autant que moi,
il va dans la même direction.
Non, je n'ai aucune inquiétude
pour l'avenir de notre mémoire.
Il y a maintenant des millions
de documents sur la Shoah.
Ils sont tous
dans des centres de documentation,
comme Yad Vashem,
comme Washington,
comme le Mémorial
de la Shoah à Paris.
Je n'ai aucune inquiétude
pour l'avenir de la mémoire.
C'est un domaine qui interpelle.
Comment un peuple qui a été...
le peuple "le plus avancé",
on peut dire,
au point de vue société,
au monde,
a pu tenter
de mettre à mort
un peuple qui est peut-être
l'un des plus anciens
encore en existence aujourd'hui.
-Serge Klarsfeld...
-Je n'ai pas d'inquiétude.
-Vous n'êtes pas inquiet. Pourtant,
de plus en plus de professeurs
de collèges et de lycées
se plaignent
de ne pas pouvoir
enseigner ou aborder
la question de la Shoah
en classe.
Certains en ont même peur.
-Oui, ça ne se passe pas
particulièrement à Paris,
ça se passe dans des périphéries,
là où il y a
des jeunes Maghrébins
dont la mémoire est altérée
et qui voudraient
que leur mémoire soit reconnue,
la mémoire des massacres
qui ont été commis
pendant la colonisation.
Il faut trouver des solutions,
mais il faut
que les professeurs
soient formés.
C'est le rôle
du Mémorial de la Shoah.
Ca avance, mais c'est très long,
l'éducation.
Il y a toujours
des soubresauts politiques
qui font que rien
n'est jamais parfait,
mais je peux dire,
quand je me reporte à la période
où moi,
j'étais tout jeune,
lycéen, étudiant,
les progrès
en ce qui nous concerne,
notre mémoire,
ont été extrêmement importants.
Il n'empêche que,
du point de vue politique,
l'un ne va pas avec l'autre.
Quand nous avons commencé
notre action,
la droite extrême était
toute petite.
Aujourd'hui,
électoralement,
elle est très importante.
-Justement, l'antisémitisme
est une maladie
qui mute et se perpétue,
particulièrement
en temps de crise.
Il touche une partie
des jeunes de banlieue
où les clichés
les plus éculés prospèrent.
Comment faire échec
à ce que les sociologues
nomment "la concurrence
"des mémoires
ou des victimes" ?
-Il faut que les problèmes
politiques soient résolus.
Si la question palestinienne
était résolue...
il y aurait beaucoup moins
de problèmes,
mais je ne suis pas là pour résoudre
les problèmes politiques.
Je suis incapable
de les résoudre.
C'est à ceux qui dirigent
les Etats
ou les entités politiques
de les résoudre.
-Vous avanciez une piste :
"Il faut relier la Shoah
"à l'aspect meurtrier
de la colonisation,
"à la question
de la supériorité des races".
-Moi, je n'ai pas de problèmes,
effectivement,
lorsque je rencontre
des gens qui sont originaires
de l'Afrique Noire
ou du Maghreb...
Je leur dis
que le sort des Juifs...
Les Juifs étaient
à peu près comme eux,
opprimés pendant très longtemps,
et que c'est à eux
de trouver les moyens,
mais il ne faut pas qu'ils oublient
qu'ils sont français,
et que les Juifs en France,
malgré les persécutions
qu'ils ont subies
dans cette période 40-44,
eh bien, sont patriotes.
Ils ne se désolidarisent pas
de la France.
Bon, il faut raison garder.
Il faut avoir du bon sens.
C'est très, très difficile
quand les passions
prennent le pas sur...
-La raison.
Justement,
un mot sur la reconnaissance
en 1995
de la responsabilité
de l'Etat français
dans la déportation
et l'extermination des Juifs.
Est-ce que ça a été
le point culminant
de votre demi-siècle de combat,
ou juste un jalon ?
-C'était un tournant,
mais ce n'était
pas la reconnaissance
de la responsabilité
de l'Etat français.
Ca, Mitterrand l'avait reconnue.
C'était la responsabilité
de la France.
C'est-à-dire,
que pour Jacques Chirac,
et j'en sais quelque chose
parce que j'en ai parlé beaucoup
avec lui avant,
eh bien,
il y avait une guerre civile
entre deux France :
la France de de Gaulle
et de la Résistance intérieure,
et la France de...
-De Vichy ?
-De Philippe Pétain
et Pierre Laval,
et c'est symptomatique.
Au mois de juin 42,
il y a eu
Bir Hakeim,
et au mois de juillet 42,
il y a eu la rafle
du Vel' d'Hiv'.
C'était une guerre civile,
et la France est responsable
aussi bien
de ce qui a été fait
en positif qu'en négatif.
C'est ce que...
Jacques Chirac a reconnu
dans sa phrase :
"Ce jour-là,
le jour de la rafle
"du Vel' d'Hiv',
"la France accomplissait
l'irréparable."
-Ca, c'est un point très important,
cette reconnaissance ?
-C'est un point très important,
parce que de là,
il en a tiré les conséquences,
et les deux gouvernements
qui ont suivi,
celui de Lionel Jospin
et d'Alain Juppé
ont créé la Fondation
pour la mémoire de la Shoah,
ont accordé une pension
aux orphelins
de la déportation,
et ont créé une commission
pour indemniser
les victimes des...
des discriminations matérielles.
-Vous vous êtes élevé
contre la réédition
de certains textes de Céline.
Ces pamphlets antisémites
assortis d'un appareil critique
n'ont aucune valeur,
d'après vous ?
-Si.
Je n'ai pas dit que...
Malheureusement,
les textes de Céline
ont eu une importance
sur beaucoup de Français
qui ont collaboré
et sur l'antisémitisme
en général,
parce qu'ils ont
un certain talent, aussi.
Je suis
pour une édition critique,
faite par un historien
comme Pierre-André Taguieff,
qui connaît parfaitement
le sujet
et qui peut démonter
toutes les sources
et tous les ressorts
de l'antisémitisme de Céline.
D'ailleurs, j'ai "garanti",
on peut dire, moralement,
ou du point de vue
de la morale politique, en tout cas,
la parution
par les éditions Fayard
de "Mein Kampf",
qui est parfaite.
-Donc, Serge Klarsfeld,
vous n'êtes pas
contre la réédition de ces textes
assortis d'un appareil critique ?
-Assortis de l'appareil critique
fait par un historien
comme Pierre-André Taguieff,
qui va dans le bon sens
et qui est prêt à élucider...
disons,
le comportement de...
de Céline.
-Votre confrère,
Henri Leclerc,
ne croit pas aux monstres.
Pourriez-vous dire
que le pire criminel
est un être humain comme un autre,
que c'est un frère ?
-Il était un frère...
Si je regarde la photo
d'Eichmann à 12 ans
et moi à 12 ans,
nous sommes pareils, mais...
à un moment...
il a choisi le mal...
et d'autres choisissent le bien,
voilà. Donc...
A partir du moment
où il a choisi le mal,
il devient un monstre
par ses actions,
mais il n'est pas un monstre
dans la vie courante.
Ca peut être un bon père,
ça peut être...
Il peut apporter
quelque chose à l'humanité,
en tant que...
technicien ou médecin, etc.
Mais à partir du moment
où il a choisi le mal...
il porte ce mal
sur les épaules.
Il a pris cette responsabilité.
Il aurait pu ne pas la prendre.
Je le dis pour les gens
qui ont un libre arbitre,
parce que les gens
qui sont au bas de la société
et qui n'ont pas eu
la chance d'étudier,
qui n'ont pas eu la chance
d'être heureux dans leur enfance,
ont des circonstances atténuantes,
pas ceux qui ont eu
une excellente éducation
et qui ont eu
les moyens de résister
à l'attrait du mal,
ou à la fascination du mal.
-Serge Klarsfeld,
vous avez contribué
à transformer l'Allemagne.
Vous avez oeuvré à la réconciliation
franco-allemande.
Vous avez permis à la mémoire
de se perpétuer
en conservant
des preuves de l'horreur.
Vous avez exigé
et obtenu réparation,
vous le disiez,
même si aucune vie perdue
n'a de prix.
Que vous reste-t-il à faire,
aujourd'hui ?
-Mourir
le plus heureusement possible.
Voilà.
-Merci, Serge Klarsfeld.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA